quella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono qua vj non
l'avreste mai detto siamo parlati su
youtubers life siamo all'episodio 3 e
stavolta sarà una bomba perché c'è una
casa nuova quindi tenetevi pronti
netgear è la madonna fonte [ __ ] case più
belle casa mia questa la nuova casa
fantastico abril frigo mangia un
sandwich
perché questa è la prima cosa che devo
fare mangiare insegne puoi vedere bello
se non abitassimo a silent hill sarebbe
un po meglio ha già giusto e vero devo
anche comprarmi da mangiare adesso vivo
da solo cazzo non avevo tenuto conto di
sta cosa
almeno non c'è mia madre dai qualcosa
c'è un solo problema ragazzi con chi
minchia vivo da chi fa aveva promesso
che facevano bunga bunga invece non c'è
siamo il mio computer ragazzi me ne devo
comprare un nuovo ciapa vj voglio
evitarti no te ne devi andare affari
cosa volete dio mio perchè dovete
andarmi a fare dei film ma cosa me ne
frega dei film patto non te la dazi ora
dare a vedere un film qualcosa se ne
frega a me la presentazione di un film
non è un film che è tipo al cinema
vicani stavolta si prova ad abbracciarti
o non ci posso credere
forse è arrivato il momento di provare a
fare il grande passo dalle un regalo e
sono due zii al semi fine zone anche
stavolta sei la persona più becera di
questo mondo
[Musica]
ho un appuntamento io la patata è una
cosa incredibile ragazzi sono contento
grazie tesoro parliamo un po e poi vado
a casa che devo fare i video e quindi
ragazzi adesso un obbligo di sentire
questa qui ogni tot perché sono mi
lascia ma non siamo ancora fidanzati ci
lasciamo solo insieme
ok lo step successivo sarà quello di
fidanzarsi wow
ma posso andare a fare una pausa per la
stampa ma chrome ma kimi sicula grazie
proprio andare fuori non sei abbastanza
famoso ma dai ma secondo te zio di
quelli che fanno i film invitano gli
youtubers all'anteprima del film per
fargli fare le foto ma sei scemo ah ok
torniamo a casa ragazzi uscire il sito e
si esce a ziano mi seguire mi mette
ansia ti prego allora meno che io non va
perché mi segue la tipa basta a seguirmi
devo andare via a posso entrare nella
hall ha quindi si vede il film amica
quello non capivo perfetto che bello
sono seduto almeno vicino alla mia tipa
prendi posto va bene questa nuova come e
in mezzo a due
ma chi sono questi mi 13 già borota
stronza io mi metto dietro e ti
controlla ma efficiente a noi ea o scusa
tesoro c è scambiato per un'altra ti
giuro mi chiamano male che non erano
ancora fidanzati siano s'incazzava come
la morte è ragazzi io vorrei vedere
vorrei vedere
vorrei vorrei posso vedere bello di
caprio sei tu questo film più bello che
abbia mai visto
ma secondo te di caprile gay
lo sa che siamo in un cinema che
parliamo lo sai che mi compro il cibo da
solo e addirittura mi pulisco la stanza
da solo stiamo parlando da almeno cinque
minuti quando è che me la dai
e finito ok è abbastanza ne vado
perfetto ho approfittato per conversare
per che cosa mi portava visto film della
minkia niente tanto faceva cagare ama
dormire che domani se fai blog c'è più
ordine in questa casa che in casa mia
come questa situazione no conca ragazzi
letto è una figata
obiettivo arriva a 50 mila iscritti
minchia milan attimo 0 dai che ci siamo
video la mia nuova casa senza patata
però vabbè a quello si rimedia che
pubblica video ci siamo ecco la ciardi
ha ri piace la nostra nuova casa dove
vivremo felici e contenti ti sto
toccando ma non è la mia intenzione
giorno se conte dove dov'è andata ma no
puoi chattare ma se i clowns dovrei
aspettare che il video sia kharja lo ha
annunciato brutta [ __ ] ti ho dato un
sacco di possibilità adesso vattene
affanculo ho capito che devo raggiungere
i 50 mila iscritti è sta minkia sono
troppi 50 milan ed elica go è un attimo
ascendendo di devo comprare nuovi
videogiochi ragazzi perché non va più
bene gioco che stavo facendo prima
quindi aspettate che compro nuovi video
già fatemi uscire shopping di videogames
lascia fini non voglio continuare questa
relazione finché non ci vedremo ancora
vasi stronza ma questa è tutta scena ma
se ci siamo visti la trota non me l'hai
data ma che poi eccolo questa è la
madonna quanto costa sto gioco costa un
sacco di soldi prove compriamo e la
madonna 49 dollari
andiamo a lavorava in certo qual è
venuta a casa mia e io ho visto un sacco
di giochi divertenti voglio provarli si
sia pro calmati che sta devo fi video io
guarda che bello non ha fissa roba
questa è arrivato gioco allora guarda
che bello è talk cioè che se ne va
brutta stronza solo per giocare i miei
videogiochi entrò in casa mia e poi esce
forza mio gaming video dove quello 9 ho
comprato
eccolo ma come fa cagare ho speso 50
dalla riva sto gioco de merda mondo moto
lo fai
allora ragazzi questo gioco è
merda però spolli chat e a caso già oggi
e tu mi hai rotto veramente il cazzo c'è
il sole fuori non so se uscire o stare
qua dentro giocare sì ma si sa ma tu
prendi casa mia come se fosse un area
giochi i nomadi melo ma io non ho parole
non ho parole ma sarai [ __ ] per questa
entra e gioca e se ne va
ma che cazzo mai preso per un game stop
o re place cosa vuol dire place
rimpiazza il computer a posso comprare
un computer
ma cos'ha fatto non lo volevo spendere i
soldi ha spiegato cosa ho fatto
sono entrato nel cestino e per questo
che spesso tutti i tuoi soldi per entra
nel cestino che bello questo qua costa
34 dollari io lo compro se fa cagare e
che hackett mario c io devo spendere 35
dollari per comprare cat mario e
compriamo questi due fi o arrivato gioco
nuovo rega ce l'abbiamo
facciamo dietro posso fare un gameplay
mentre carica il video si vero zio
perché non è che c'è il computer di
merda o f
una storia bellissima episodio 17 prende
views se sei scrivo tette da viaggio sto
caricando video sta caricando video sto
caricando video stoccoro in quanto video
vai a casa tua e poi lavorava va a
lavorare di mortacci sua vai il mio
computer deve usare sempre il mio
computer deve usare questa minchia ci
siamo ragazzi stiamo per fare il white
troupe di questo gioco bello che ciò che
di merda cos'è il welfare e che credo
che sia carina la lida lega altro perché
credo che possa fare una serie di video
senza che videogioco passi mai di moda
cioè finché non lo finisco quindi dovrei
riuscire a fare un sacco di views spero
è non lo scopo e magari non è così cat
mare hackett mario ma sempre views e
regala non capito perché cat mario mi
incazzo e uccido le persone dalla rabbia
da vedere clicca qui ecco la zia devi
devi darti dal caso sto giocando io che
mi gioco video sarà epico vara la tipa
che si vede di sfondo ma quanto sei
stupido sto registrando donna va fuori
dai [ __ ]
pensavi di una bomba pubblica levati
dalle pene vai a casa tua
poi pero che gli chiedo l'appuntamento
io non ho parole
cinquantamila views cazzo quanto ha
fatto questo video prima il video più
con più chiuso comunque questo è 53mila
piuss quante sono madonna è tantissimo è
20 ragazzi conclude abbiamo bisogno di
youtubers life conti però nel prossimo è
come se i ragazzi è un gioco identico mi
sembri fa la stessa cosa nella vita
reale è veramente un deja vu pazzesco
prove se vi è piaciuta assolutamente mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook e
come mi ha dato una descrizione sono
stati scritti lì noi ci arriviamo ad un
prossimo video da ragazzi prima o poi mi
ammazzerò questo telecomando lo so